it's like trying to find the right
balance between like i
i got my integrity you know i want to be
a good person
but at the same time it's just the world
is making it super [ __ ] hard
sometimes
and it it's you know it it [ __ ] sucks
that it's this way
but i mean it's just that like war
between the the traditionalist way of
doing things and then the new age things
of doing that right because you know
like
even if youtube right now is such a
massive thing worldwide
technically speaking it's only been
around for what 15 years yeah i mean
it's just i feel like it's just the age
of social media now yeah where people
it is all about making as much noise as
possible even if
you are someone very much in the wrong
and like your logic is [ __ ]
somehow some people are able to make
more noise than the other person
therefore they are the right ones yeah
and they win in the end and it's just
like
it's a very i would say backwards way
but it's just the way the world is now
the hands we've been dealt unfortunately
with youtube system um yeah
it's really sad that it only ever gives
uh any benefit to the claimant so yeah
you kind of don't really have a choice
and yeah it sucks because
people who don't want to do it i mean
like i i don't want to do it like i
don't want to make it fast about it on
twitter and i probably might have been
able to get it resolved if i just made
it hell for them
like if i just you know bomb their
social medias yeah that might have
worked like but
did i want to find out and would i have
felt good about it like probably not you
know yeah yeah
right yeah exactly yeah it's horrible
because the thing about especially with
youtube copyright is that there's just
been like
ev everything is everything that's been
mentioned and everything that people say
is all [ __ ] guess work because the
thing is there is no precedence
because the highest level this can go up
to is like
supreme court it's like right and that's
only happened once between one creator
and one creator which is like h3h3
right yeah and that's been the only
precedence about
anything regarding youtube copyright
that we've never had an individual go up
against the company so
nobody knows how that's going to end up
really you know i think because
the company doesn't really want that
because it would look bad for that and
no individual wants to be the test
yeah yeah exactly right nobody wants to
be the first yeah do you really want to
be that company picking on a singular
dude and then that dude also rallied the
internet behind him like you probably
don't want that
yeah it's not you might win it but you
ever think you're an adult
in that situation kind of everyone loses
yeah like there is no
single winner at that point no no maybe
the creator can come out of it
if he's willing to go through it like
the creator might come out with a lot of
respect
and might get a lot of community support
and yeah it could be worth it but it's
such a big gamble
right it could also completely go the
other way around you can also completely
just ruin your life
well it could not only bankrupt that
individual but it could also leave an
example for other companies
yeah yeah yeah exactly it's like oh well
they lost in the court case so uh let's
let's go out and just [ __ ] snipe down
all these individual creators yeah
because [ __ ] nobody understands uh
nobody
[ __ ] understands the law anyway no so
it's we
none of us under really understand fair
use laws how the [ __ ] are the [ __ ]
jury can understand fair use laws
you know what i mean like so so what you
you used an anime girl
in your video and this company owns said
anime girl but doesn't actually own it
yeah
it's like yes your honor geez and it's a
mess given how worldwide youtube is like
how do you how do you sue someone
that's in like a different country with
different laws yeah exactly you know
what if your none of your american
company which laws are you using do you
using youtube well
that's the problem right is that like
i'm not an expert so right yeah
and i think that's why like at least the
majority of anime youtubers who have
been caught using anime footage in their
videos have
managed to get away with it because in
japan we don't have fair use laws
but in america where youtube is hosting
we do have fair use
yeah so it just never happens the
japanese look at that and we're like oh
[ __ ] well
i guess we've got to back away worth
that time either to you know
try and figure out who if they can do it
yeah it is an unfair system because it
really
like it really just [ __ ] over any of
the small creators oh yeah you know what
i mean and
i feel like the if you're a small
creator the best strategy you can go for
is be friends like a bigger creator you
know what i mean yeah because if you're
any
if you're in ever in any trouble then
you've got to rely on them
to like make noise for you because you
can't do it for yourself
um and i can't really think of a better
way to go about it
aside from that except just [ __ ]
giving up
there's literally no other way of going
around that right yeah it sucks
yeah it's kind of unfortunate even like
creative our sizes it's still difficult
to get things fixed i think the only
creators like i could think of that
would be like
able to get [ __ ] done it's like like mr
beast because he's like obviously
you should if you youtube yeah youtube's
really friendly with you
they'll help you out yeah they'll
they'll figure out a way to make it like
go away yeah but it's like one out of
how many million channels that's the
thing
right there's like maybe like 100 i bet
no more than 100 of those people who can
have that kind of yeah yeah because even
i like i mean we're like big creators i
guess
i mean we're we're big creators in the
anime field but in the overall [ __ ]
scheme of things we're we're just a
[ __ ]
decently sized though like yeah but
there's i think i saw this like
i think in 2020 like beginning of 2020
uh like rough estimate
there's i think over 10 000 channels now
with over a million subs
wow so yeah it's uh we're definitely not
we're definitely
you know expanding more but you still
think that the ad revenue that you're
maybe bringing in
you know is more than like a google
employee so it might be worth
right but how many google employees are
there
at the end of the day yes we may be big
in our separate fields and maybe
compared to other like smaller creators
or people who don't do stuff
but in a bigger sense the ceiling is
very very high
it should be nice because you know they
take 45 of your ad revenue it'd be nice
to know that they
give a [ __ ] about it you know how much
you host the videos yeah
i mean they're big enough where like
they don't care about it like one one
million crate one million subscribers
that's like nothing true
true yeah i guess they only care about
the creators that can actually affect
their reputation which is
the super big
yeah yeah because i mean i get it when
like you see on twitter that we are due
to like 20 subs he's like man were
youtube's so unfair to the small guys
and it's like i mean
i mean come on you have 20 subs like
i mean you don't really like have much
to lose like i know i know like
you should you know shouldn't be
discriminating against sizes but also
i think there should be a prioritize on
people who are living off it and
use the system through it throughout i
mean it's like i
i feel sorry for youtube at the same
time as well because
i'm like i'm like like as i'm thinking
about this from like their perspective
and like how do you
solve every problem that you have on
youtube because youtube right now is
too [ __ ] large it's there's too much
content to be able to know what
everything is everyone is doing and
everything being uploaded like it feels
like it's just an impossible puzzle to
solve you you
you jiggle around one thing and then
like another piece pops out you know
what i mean that's what it feels like
where
it's i feel like they are doing the best
that they can
and i feel like as creators we all like
are very grateful to youtube
but the the sucky thing is that if we
have a problem with youtube we have to
make them look like the [ __ ] devil
yeah you know what i mean
whereas my my personal opinion is that i
know youtube's doing the best they can
i know there's like some massive
problems that happen with you know some
people getting banned or some people
getting demonetized
by like accidents and everything and it
can can affect livelihood but i look at
this
also from like the perspective of hey
this is this platform is just [ __ ]
massive it's
gonna be impossible to solve every
problem with a bot but that's
what they need to do they need to have a
bot because you can't have
actual humans looking over everything
that's being uploaded yeah because
hasn't like youtube
hasn't youtube like in in terms of like
stuff that google owns hasn't youtube
been in the red for like the past like
four years or something like that yeah
it's constantly losing but i mean it's
it's not the
value of making money the amount of
information that youtube brings google
is like priceless oh yeah yeah it's like
what 50 hours of content uploaded every
minute or second
i think it's way more than that i think
it's more weird
it's insane yeah but no it's it's it's
scary but i guess like that comes with
the price
of it being just a brand new type of
entertainment right i'm sure radio and
tv had
probably the exact same problems when it
first started to arise and it's only
yeah after decades and decades of trial
and error that they've kind of smoothed
it out i mean what
what i find funny is that when youtube
first started to get super super
commercialized right
um and people started having all these
problems with copyright and
a lot of a lot of people taking
advantage of the system people like well
this is this is a [ __ ] dying platform
let's go over to twitch everyone and
then now now that twitch is like
starting to like
burst into the mainstream yeah we're now
seeing like the same problems
affect twitch creators now everyone's
like man twitch is getting
twitch is getting so hard we're just
twitches getting axed like
even harder yeah yeah exactly like the
new dmca laws are bloody ridiculous on
twitch now yeah
yeah and it was it was like the one
thing that twitch was like oh thank god
we don't have to worry about
playing copyrighted stuff on our twitch
anymore and then twitch was like
oh amazon kind of stepped in was like
yeah about that i mean it's it's it's
more like the
music industry has just been like stuck
in its ways for like the past like 30
years which is weird though because you
used to
we just read that because like websites
like new grounds
to this day you can use copyrighted
music and they won't do anything
that's cause no one owns new grounds
newgrounds is like uh still privately
owned
right but the thing is is like even when
it was in its prime like the music
industry never stepped in
and tried to do something about it they
were just like well because the money
wasn't there yeah like when the live
streaming
they see all these like billion dollar
buyers oh yeah i guess i'm seeing the
music industry like hello
like basically i feel like it's just the
content cycle like everyone
tries to find this new platform where we
i mean we talked about the golden age of
the internet before where
things were like less regulated and
everything but as soon as something
does get popular enough it's it's just
an inevitability
that companies are just going to want to
get internet and it's going to be more
regulated
and it's going to be you're going to
have content creators are just going to
have less freedom it's the
unfortunate truth of the internet and
it's the unfortunate truth of media
god i hate capitalism
down with capitalism